So are we planning to migrate the others because
They are migrating for the future of their kids
Health care is said to be better
and
Education abroad
At least six of them are connected to it
They are said to be paid digits
They still choose
To migrate
Just story time momshies and papshies
So we are the ones
Our household is
Double income
Household
Hubby and I both earned six digits
Monthly
We are also in the IT field
And to be honest
I thought about it once
Like a few years back I thought when we migrated
As in which I am already talking to agencies
I already know those
requirements
But after
Two to three years why are we still here in Pinas
Because you need a lot
Consider
Before you migrate
One of the things we did is
I computed the cost of living
If we were in australia
How much will it be?
We are there
Compared
to be
We here at Pinas
Given all the bills
To pay including health care and tuition fees
In our case there is no
Difference
What we can collect in australia and here in pinas
Of course,
you can really think about what
What about that
At least there free
That's not it
It's automatic
Free in australia
If it is remembered
Correctly
PR needed
That's the one
Citizen
Your status in australia before becoming
That's free
So if you enter there with a work visa you will pay
That's still it
And then you have
To wait for five years before PR applies to you
The first thing we do
This is considered
What we can save abroad
second
The career we will leave behind
Are we willing
To start from scratch again
Because here our career is okay
Like me,
I only work for a few hours but I earn six
Digits
And to be honest hubby's career
Is far more blessed
His saturation is far compared to mine at the same time
The time is good too
His career here in Pinas
So that's it
Career is one of the things we consider
Because if we are willing
To give that up and start over again
Third
The comfort
We here in Pinas so we have two houses
Health who has been
Helping me
Managing the house
Also taking care of Liam
If they don't I'm actually tired I'm tired mi
Then if intended
We are still children again
And I have nothing to partner with
There because of course hubby needs it
Do work
It's a scenario that we also had to consider
Are we willing to igive up
The comfort we are now experiencing
Daycare is an indication of that
Service in australia is very expensive
If let's say that
Your household costs
One thousand AUD
a month
If everyday you need to take care of your child
That is five hundred aud
That is one
Third of your total
Monthly cost
And I don't know
Can I leave
My son at daycare
I don't leave my son here
I work from home
When returning
I'm to office
I still leave my son with his grandparents
Just to be sure
He is really taken care of
Ayun Mamshie so for now is not in the plans
We will migrate
Because given how much we earn
How much we are able to save invest
Now we are slowly building those
Our investment and hopefully soon
I will also share our journey with you
The comfort
We have it like not winning win
situation for us
To go to australia
To be honest
God is good and I can say we are very blessed
That it is a
For us we don't need to think about that
Migration migration
But of course we have his reason
Why these are the decisions we make